[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous bonjour
federica bonjour j me et bonjour garcin
malsa voilà alors vous êtes le président
du modemas le mouvement des démocrates
écologistes pour une martinique
souveraine est aussi président du mir
martinique le mouvement international
pour les réparations donc de la deûle
esclavage et de la déportation donc des
africains aux amériques
justement tiens on va commencer par ça
garcin malsa avant de parler des
préparatifs des municipales notamment à
sainte anne dont vous avez été longtemps
le maire il faut le rappeler aussi et
puis avant d'évoquer le sujet du
chlordécone est une action demain une
action un peu chaude qui est prévu du
côté de fort de france près d'une grande
surface mais avant ça lemire martinique
après l'île de gorée au sénégal l'an
dernier le il ya eu un convoi bas
réparation du mir en afrique
un deuxième convoi cette année au bénin
vous avez séjourné une délégation de 40
membres du mir a séjourné pendant quinze
jours au bénin et s'est rendu notamment
dans la ville de ouidah
voilà alors ça s'est bien passé donc ce
deuxième voyage après le sénégal l'an
dernier car ça malsain déjà sans
privilège pour moi de prouver commercial
messi a toute latitude première et non
seulement ça passait bien mais ç'a
dépassé toute l'espagne des gains passés
de gré trouver du recueil nous depuis le
début le montrent les lie au pont
jusqu'à nous paty et dit non anselmo
deux cas passé vous êtes chez vous
saclay et pendant tout c'est vous la
nous comporter que nous exactement quand
des béninois qu'ondine martiniquais
compte des infos descendants nous
rencontrer les autorités politiques mais
ouidah qui était extraordinaire qui dit
non conscient il a déjà au mieux et
d'ailleurs c'est lui qui crée pin ou
amis ou bennett cognant aussi au niveau
du sénégal non russie voit effectivement
et accueillir les
autorité spirituelle les autorités
effectivement quitte à gallica
surveiller toute la partie du patrimoine
et du bénin et au delà du patrimoine
devenu le roi dalanda leroy et de dudu
de dudu des retraites
voyons alors nous faille des x men aussi
qu effectivement niveau destruction
semoun un cancer frappe et nous alors
c'est un gars très mal ça nous plaît pas
free fait tout voyage là mais qui sans
ce votre cabas à ces voyages talla pucci
lemire martinique est allé sénégal bénin
mais sa rentrée en disant même sanoga
dit en thérapie en auto réparations
parce que le nom car les faits qu'on
voit nous matinik nos caddies de nougat
fentes et rapidement sans auto et par
action est ce un bon staff et
s'accomplit faut pour mener combat
poussent à nous demander pour exiger que
les skavens la traite négrière en
contrepartie un crime contre l'humanité
plus bas nous réparation et là nous
trouver au bénin que nous trouver au
sénégal et nesat est encore petit foc
damon qui accueillit nous très fort y
pratiquer accompagne s'inscrit par
action
et bien la laine ou discuter pied ou de
santis a essayé chitika conduit au
bâtiment d'une empathie bien new way
surtout des monkey cas travail a mené un
raid manteau en jeunesse qui en
mouvement nous aident et montrent qu'il
n'ya capacités intellectuelles
extraordinaire pleine capacité
le cac de gérer tout ça nous car oui
effectivement
et bien et les actes est tout ce qui
nous vaut aujourd'hui you the grudge à
nyon côtés d'autres cas les poux
prochain convoi en afrique afin
prochainement puisque 20e anniversaire
la ici assez l'année prochaine c'est
quand même bitume bagages et puis
l'année prochaine alors un long moment
cap à l'est du ghana
halloween est un baume sur le ghana
d'autres cas d'yves aussi fort que nous
et est allé d'autre côté que le ghana
nous pour ça mais c'est le ghana qui est
prioritaire nous guette tout ça très
bien allez on passe donc à la politique
maintenant garcin malsa alors il y en a
qui s'ils perdent un peu entre nous
peuple a le modemas pays a ki moon qui a
demandé masse ki moon qui par adam nous
peuples encore mais qui a dans pays à
enfin donc comment ça se présente toute
cette affaire là et vous me regarde pas
mal ça comment vous vous situez est ce
que par exemple nous paie plassac
existait toujours
est-ce que nous peuple la fonde hadopi a
pas de politique la paix déjà brillant
monde et masques existait effectivement
tout pas tout non correctement des
masques à organiser des manifestations
et le cncp puits de calès et que c'était
donc ça sent premier bagage et puis mon
des masses et inspirer nos peuples à
céline aspirations de nos peuples est
une idée mon dieu nous peuple à qui
allait à dinan payant mais nous paie
plaque à exister et sa fac les poumons
il n'y a pas de paroles parfois la cave
une ex aequo et très bientôt
ben caspit york a demandé dix vignettes
mais cole et porte parole a
effectivement semaad lietti les écailles
vénitienne qui s'est exprimé en des
backing commun la place de permettent
sac à exister alors les municipales à
sainte-anne puisqu'on est donc dans les
préparatifs votre positionnement votre
avis compte puisque vous avez été on le
rappelle un nouveau longtemps longtemps
à la tête de la ville vous étiez maire
de sainte-anne garcin malsa et puis là
donc il ya le maire sortant qui entend
se représenter jean-michel j'ai mieux
et puis il y a deux amis à vous en
quelque sorte qui se sont annoncés
candidat pierre haïr et joël joseph mehr
helix l'actuel d'ailleurs président de
l'asso pamart alors qu'est ce qui se
passe il n'y a pas d'unité écologie
locke alors écologistes plutôt récentes
élections deux gars à lécousse khoury et
nîmes en cap ou seydou vent et des
gouttes ig group dit hugo puisque qu'à
former coyot parce qu'effectivement yoka
d'y penser c'est les meilleurs une piste
notoriété etc etc
tout ça c'est des problèmes individuels
qui qu'a posée par danger talent et non
pas bon pendant 25 ans l'habitude de
fonctionner concerts ont collecté un
collectif et ça c'est très fort c'est en
tout cas ce n'est seulement qu'à
soutiennent pied aux ayew
mais ça c'est pierre aux ayew c'est le
candidat du modemas si les nous cassent
une dizaine mettant possède une place et
procédures la viper aux ayew est tout
petit moulin quitté calais a quitté
d'e-banking compétences je dis comme ça
dès lors nous soutienne un candidat
knockout génie et ça effectivement parce
qu'ils y travaillent
puis quand j'arriverai conseillers
municipaux si on est des dossiers 10 ans
l'écologiste hills un battant il emmène
du temps à créer un leader et sa célèbre
et qui très important sacré pour tout le
monde nous parle à la fête ni filiation
népotisme
nicu secouru par un soutien du monde
parce que effectivement c'est peut-être
enfin mis un pneu panama est dallas sa
maman en question de vision partagée et
vision collective et ses concerts nous
avancer 517 en panne à 25 ans et il n'ya
en municipalité qu'il a effectivement
mais si pas été bourru mais il n'y a sur
le grand cadi band
pendant cinq ans il fait sa nouba fait
bondir 25 ans sachant que vous avez fort
bourguiba et à la lehman connaître
effectivement sano météo incertaine pour
l'ensemble de matinée cook a évoqué
actifs adam campagne municipale traque
est finie pour le moment compte tenu de
samantha a présenté jeudi joue non
seulement sainte anne les matinik et au
delà de matinée mais n'ont pas très bien
alors on en vient à la sphère du
chlordécone quelques mots vraiment
rapidement parce que je voudrais qu'on
parle de cette manifestation de boycott
qui circulent la dont il ya un appel qui
circule sur les réseaux sociaux y
compris sur le relayer d'ailleurs sur le
site du mir j'ai vu ça ce matin la
commission d'enquêté parlementaire sur
les conséquences du chlordécone alors
tout accès ensuite alors c'est pas
première fois qu'à faire comme sienne
enquête par la chlordécone mouiller ses
points faibles qu'à parler de ça oui
donc effectivement toute action qu'aller
dans le sens dit obligé l'état français
et puis obligé ces mots qui bat l'état
français injonction sa du cbt pour que
problème claude et bonnan et résoudre
enfin faveur du peuple martiniquais et
bien toute action bon le paka paka quid
ne pas cacher à ses pièces actions et
nous quand même 10 et n'a quitté y ait
quitté pour l'épandage aérien
si aucun défenseur d'épicier au caddie
dites vous diop ou la réparation sans
très bon bagage mais faut que le savent
s'ils nous en situation et à l'âge aux
dix jours c'est parce que premier
réparation réparation du crime contre
l'esclavagé crime qui effectivement
contre l'humanité le comedd panel
esclavage à sous les descendants
d'africains déportés ici à et bien c'est
parce que ben attallah pas résoudre
et si l'outil résoudre les petits gars
là je dis je c'est pour ça donc appelé
ses mines d'alès vaudou à coller
peut-être que les épaules et pis l'union
pour battre ensemble pour prochain
convoi a quitté l'union pour nous battre
sous question de réparation peau pour
expliquer réparation à sous beaucoup
beaucoup contre l'humanité rappelé qu'à
ça
le président du mir je les dis le
mouvement international pour les
réparations de martinique qui relaie cet
appel au boycott alors avec une petite
en tête nation matnik qui est un
mouvement prochain aussi d'unir qui fait
partie peut-être du collectif du mir je
ne sais pas nation matnik oui toutes ces
miles a et o soit sorti a dit d'un
boudin à saint-amand et puis hop at il
des raisons à l'actionnaire soit ut1
didaoui puis ok c'était alors après ça a
collé tout ça rappelle tac à 17h30 on a
rapidement le commandement des matinées
palais carrefour dillon samedi 19
octobre
voilà notamment des sacs ip vini barry
epinoux d'épinés veut alors faire
soutient ça nous fait appel à
l'intelligence collective
la semaine passée mais la passe est très
bien et nous a fait appel à
l'intelligence collective et réfléchie
de magnifier le pack à la casse ne pas
caler à l'opposition vis-à-vis des
matchs contre cavaillon nous pas de la
baguette à la meinau cadix et moulins
c'est un test for faudrait pas présenté
comme la pièce puisque toutes ses côtés
1 et i que ses descendants
d'esclavagistes croyons indemnisés est
un nouvel agent
et puis au cas semenya là on est donc en
voie du lot nous cacher à boycotter ou
sans permis action car elle est beaucoup
plus sain et sa cabane au plus fort
pourquoi tous ces mots naked en
commission parlementaire la llo réagir
manière beaucoup plus fort et notre
appui proposition de motta qu'amendé
qu'effectivement
tous ces ministres qui tenait depuis
1972 la et interviews quant à passer ça
excellent d'accord donc on retient que
vous soutenez l'action pour ce samedi
effectivement le seuil c'est celui qui
sait mesurer le travail fait dans le
temps et le travail
l'espace et qui effectivement veille à
ce que l'oeuvre des insectes des anciens
les anciennes générations soient
respectées pour les générations futures
donc en tant que sage merci garcin malsa
d'avoir participé à ce 5 à 10 bonnes
journées
[Musique]